le climat revient au centre du débat
mondial lors d'un sommet virtuel
pandémie de covile 19 oblige si les
émissions de co2 ont baissé de 7 % en
2020 grâce aux nombreux confinement à
poser à travers le monde
le réchauffement climatique continue
malgré tout de gagner du terrain
pour la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen
l'activité humaine en est la cause
le premier ministre britannique boris
johnson estime quant à lui que le défi
climatique et plus dévastateurs que
l'épidémie de coronavirus ensemble nous
pouvons utiliser les avancées
scientifiques pour protéger l'ensemble
de notre planète et notre biosphère
contre un défi bien pire
bien plus destructeur même que le
coronavirus et grâce aux pouvoirs
prométhéen de notre inventivité nous
pouvons commencer à défendre la terre
contre le désastre du réchauffement
climatique global
cinq ans après la coop 21 il était temps
de faire le point sur les engagements
pris par les 195 pays signataires des
accords de paris l'objectif d'une
augmentation de la température globale à
2 degrés à l'horizon 2100 semble
compromis le secrétaire général de
l'organisation des nations unies
appellent les gouvernements a déclaré je
cite l'état d'urgence climatique
cinq ans après paris nous ne sommes
toujours pas sur la bonne foi et donc
l'objectif principal des nations unies
pour 2021 et de construire une véritable
coalition mondiale pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone d'ici le milieu du
siècle mais cette promesse ne suffit pas
pour en faire une réalité
nous devons procéder dès maintenant à
des réductions significatives afin de
diminuer les émissions mondiales de co2
de 45 % d'ici 2030 par rapport aux
niveaux de 2010 ce samedi plusieurs pays
ont pris des engagements climatiques
plus fort pour améliorer la santé de la
planète
c'est le cas de la chine désormais
premier pays émetteur de carbone au
monde qui soit réduire ses émissions de
co2 de 65 % d'ici à 2030
il en va de même pour les 27 pays de
l'union européenne qui ont trouvé un
accord pour réduire leurs émissions de
carbone d'au moins 55 % d'ici à la
prochaine décennie
emmanuel macron attend lui que les états
unis
réintègre l'accord de paris après
l'investiture de joe biden
nous nous retrouvons dans un moment qui
est important quelques jours après que
le président élu des etats unis
d'amérique est affirmé sa volonté de
revenir dans l'accord de paris je veux
vraiment dire
welcome back qualcomm rom à nos amis
américains
l'enjeu climatique sera toujours dans
les agendas l'année prochaine reporté en
raison de la pandémie actuelle la coop
26 se tiendra à glasgow au royaume uni à
la fin de l'année 2021